I think I think we've successfully begun
recording if you're watching this it it
worked I hear it
I don't say uh that's a pretty uh
potentially big leap there well it
doesn't matter if no one's watching it
then I don't look stupid right like
it'll be a perfect crime
very apropos prior conversations here I
had a video fail on a podcast recording
part way through recently so the host
went on like mid-journey and generated a
description of our conversation and put
that on the oh that's fun as the
replacement speaking of AI it's weirding
me out that you're super superimposed on
your own background that is there's
something like uncanny valley about the
whole thing yeah I couldn't resist the
Phantom piano for the sake of the old
days
I have no fingers there we go that's
good uh yeah it's very believable
looking Studio I'm sorry I'm cool I'm
sorry I've called attention to it I've
obviously ruined the illusion now for
everyone watching
um yeah I just love the it's kind of
like stop motion there's just like this
little Jitter around the edges yeah I
like how if I put my hand here it kind
of exposes my chair
um a little bit of tile it's amazing
isn't it if you do have to stop and
think like how impressed like 10 year
old you would be with the technology
we're all bored of at this point
oh there's a nerd like how long did you
download that Phantom Menace trailer for
you know like and now it's just like all
of everything dude I'll never forget
uh Dark Forces
uh the first person shooter of LucasArts
mid 90s they made a sequel called Jedi
Knight
then made an expansion what we now call
DLC but was in fact a box title but was
an expansion called Mysteries of the
Sith in which you played as Mara Jade
and that game boasted that they had
color volumetric lighting
uh like you would walk into a space and
it wasn't just lit it was lit with like
purple light and that was novel and it
was but it was two men 64 the animated
likes for the first time in a doom and
that blew everyone's mind the idea of
Lights had changed was yeah impossible
impossible unbelievable and like the
first time I saw ragdoll physics where I
was used to playing Shooters where if
you happen to kill a bad guy at the top
of the stairs they were like this wooden
plank out over the abyss from the top
because it registered them as being on
the The Landing at the at the top of the
stairs but they fell toward them so
there was just like stairs and then this
corpse you know very severe rigor mortis
and uh the first yeah sometimes you
still see that sometimes In fairness it
still happens but the fact that now you
more often the thing is this you'd like
the over aggressive ragdoll physics
um of a of a body that's like
cartoonishly follow falling down the
stairs
how
technologically just Out Of Reach that
was for for the whole the whole of my
gaming upbringing it's so true when I
look now at like which is video calls
like even stuff that's more mundane or
we would think of as more the idea that
I'm talking you know over the Atlantic
with you via video and we can both kind
of see each other is incredible yeah
third Earth a third Earth away yeah uh
yeah it's it's pretty astonishing I
remember one that blew my mind recently
that gave me exactly the sentiment that
you're describing where I thought
now that's
um a thing that if I was exposed to as a
kid
might have broken my brain was I was
looking at like an Instagram filter or
no no I was I was on um Angela called me
over Facebook messenger and they have
all these silly filters
um and I one of them puts you in like a
black and white
like comic kind of graphic novel space
okay
[Music]
no it's like it's like it's like almost
like News newspaper cartoon oh okay like
peanuts kind of thing yeah yeah very
very like just thin black and white uh
line art you know no no even shading or
anything just very very basic but like
very convincingly that aesthetic and
then I realized it's rendered in 3D and
if I'm on my call and I just rotate the
background moves with me like it put me
in a space that they had built out
in like a little 3D kind of model that
it gives you a camera positioning and
actually moves relative using presumably
the accelerometer or whatever on your
phone and the image tracking yeah it's
wild that's amazing yeah and I and I
thought and this is like this is the
point of this is so that on a call
I can click it and make the other person
go oh that's funny and then that's it
it's done it has served its purpose it
has nothing beyond the flash of of a
cracked smile uh on behalf of the
recipients that's awesome 80 of human
creativity and invention has been talked
about making someone smirk a little bit
and feel happy like that's that's pretty
much uh yeah that's we're all trying to
impress someone aren't we you know I
think that's a very fair assessment I
just
I don't know how much work went into
creating a thing like like that but I
know that for the majority of my life
that would have been considered like
when you just think about what a
revolution it was when you saw Toy Story
the first
fully 3D animated and it was like
this is I can't believe this I've never
seen anything like this you know and
it's just yeah it's it's funny how you
try to never hurt men with Mike and
Austin old men with Mike Austin I was
gonna say back in our day it's also
great when you go back and watch old
sci-fi like how badly Minority Report
has aged not for any of the massive
predictions but because they're all
using discs
and just that looks so weirdly
anachronistic now but they are it's
discs isn't it like little glass like
trans people yeah yeah they're cool but
I think the cool part is but yeah when
they're walking too fast
when they're walking through the public
spaces and the ads are like John
anderton have you bought life insurance
or whatever like that one's pretty much
that one's pretty much already here
um and uh and and in fact
around the stuff you're enjoying yeah
exactly John anderton have you bought
this anti-police you know evasion
software yeah
yeah that that whole film The the I was
just talking to somebody the other day
about how I think it is a it is a
criminally underrated Spielberg film
that the whole sequence where he's
hitting the eye transplants uh and he's
lying in the bathtub and the little
spider droids are hunting for him and
the camera is doing this long take up
through the ceiling where they've built
this whole set of adjacent apartments
and so the camera could fly in and out
and come down and up and back up on a
crane and all as a single long take
before that was reference we use that as
reference for John Wick hex like that
was the the idea like I love that scene
the kind of that overview and then you
know that you say that I feel like I
remember us talking about that we had
forgotten
I like I think I think what's beautiful
about this is a magical thing that
happens when you combine like Philip K
dicks like cynicism and Spielberg's
utter lack of cynicism like yeah like
that kind of it's just it's peanut
butter and jelly man it just works
couldn't agree more to me the the Dual
the the double whammy of around 2000 of
minority port and AI where because AI
had the same chocolate peanut butter of
the Kubrick and Spielberg
um and yeah he he that seems to bring
out especially these days
where the unbridled optimism
um like I'm a very optimistic person but
it's just one of those weird or somehow
susceptible to those Zeitgeist shifts
where I look at the thing and I go
it
ET is one of the greatest films ever
made and it makes me cry like a little
child if E.T came out today unchanged it
would read as cheesy and oh yeah and and
but in a ways that I don't I don't see
it as cheesy I see it it's not the world
changing or is that just you getting
older do you think well I think I think
it's I think it's like the world changes
because the people change so like you
can't resist it's like on a certain
level we're just susceptible to
the Zeitgeist shifts uh like I like I I
I'm I'm perhaps less so because I really
like those optimistic feel good things
although I I [ __ ] love Andor and it's
the most cynical that Star Wars has ever
been by far
um so like I look at it and I go I'm I'm
kind of over the bright-eyed Luke
Skywalker Adventurer sort of default
position of Star Wars at least letting
it rest for a time and going into this
just full-on dystopian
I'm a few episodes behind you so I'm
going to be very careful with myself but
the um
I haven't watched today's no I'm I've
only seen up to seven because I'm
watching it okay it's like I'm pretty
sure every episode is better than the
one before like 100 years yeah I just
think it's taking the material seriously
I don't think it's I wouldn't say it's
necessarily more cynical than Stars I
think it's just engaging seriously with
the idea of rebellion and and of of
fascism like you know it's it's taking
the source material seriously it's
respecting The Source material I think
it's I think I think there's a truth to
that however maybe cynical was the wrong
word maybe that's a misdiagnosis rather
because it's more like
ultra realistic whereas the originals
are
a fantasy it's not it's a it's literally
it is literally like Tolkien in space
kind of style of of let's build a world
and let's build a very Joseph Campbell
archetypal adventure and and while the
World building is shockingly thorough it
is not as much about that whereas and
orange okay let's zoom in on the World
building for a bit it's making the soft
text text isn't it it's making the it's
making yeah it's pulling up those way to
put it the people in the background are
becoming the story which is also what
was good about uh Rogue one as well but
yeah yeah exactly so uh yeah you
definitely need to get caught up
to that an actor I've worked with I hear
is about doing some very interesting
stuff in uh oh my God just when you
think you've got him pegged as like
someone who you you know you're like
I've seen what he's capable of uh he
just pulls out something where you're
like man the vulnerability in what he's
I think he's incredible people
underestimate oh we're talking about for
anyone who doesn't understand we're
talking about Andy Circus who who I've
had the pleasure and he's and but yeah
he's brought up in Entertainment Weekly
it's gonna have any circus and then
parentheses
um
yeah 100 I got I got him I got he he
recorded this stuff for volume I I it
was he was on a day off from I must have
been Force awakens and he was going to
his kids birthday party and he recorded
on the way there
um so yeah no I I'm obviously a key part
of his career yeah but no he but no he's
he's like a lot of actors who are very
good
um at doing roles in kind of popular
entertainment he's wildly underestimated
at every turn like he is phenomenally
good fire uh because he was getting so
much credit for Smeagol and there was a
little bit of this pushback of like VFX
people and yeah he's done that half of
this performance
um and I remember looking at and going
yeah but I've watched the the like
behind the scenes of him just walking
around in the performance capture suit
and especially when you watch him in
these other roles he's done and like
that is relaxing that is that is not
that is not just throwing a suit and it
all happens I think he I think that was
an unfortunate turn the phrase where he
referred to like motion captures like
wearing costume I think that was that
kind of stuff was offensive oh I see I
see like because the animations
I I I don't think intentionally like
from you know from like I said he's a
he's a good bloke so I assume it was uh
I assume it was as we've all done said
an error quickly to a journalist and
regretted for the rest of time you know
it's it's yeah
yeah it was kind of a candid thing that
got away I don't know he I obviously uh
um
no
um uh
direct I've never interacted with him
but but just seeing the evolution of his
roles over the last 20 ish years since
the since uh ever since volume I think I
think that was the moment volume was the
Turning Point yeah yeah that happened
and then heralded the uh Kevin feige and
it was like you'd be kind of like I'm
gonna say I discovered him but I kind of
discovered him
smeagle was like this amazing I was like
you know this kid's Gonna Go Far yeah
um
the uh but yeah to that subject though
of cheesy it is so like
um
I don't like to think that I've gotten
um
cynical
or
that I've like when you said the you
know has has the world moved on like
it's a genuinely interesting question
that I that I think about where it's
like certain games
did you play Return to Monkey Island
oh not yet it's I'm I've got my backlog
is wild at the moment yeah I will get to
it I'm Conway it kind of It kind of
deals with this question in a way but I
don't want to I don't want to go any
further and uh for a sake of spoilers
but like it's one of those that while
playing it I had this initial feeling of
like
um
I
was
somehow expecting something new or
expecting something different or and I
was initially like you know maybe maybe
this like the exact formula of the early
90s point-and-click Adventure
is it resonating quite as uh with me
these days but then at some point the
game is like
you know
we as game designers see what you're
aimed at and we're that that idea is
going to make its way into the actual
fabric of the game
um and so it has its own kind of in a
way meta commentary on itself in a sense
yeah uh but I won't say any more uh but
to me it ended up being very affecting I
by the end of the game I was actually
quite taken by it because I was like wow
they this is also a study of that
progression like that we all go through
and when we look back at something that
we did 30 years ago and and we have to
examine our relationship with it as just
fundamentally new people
um it's an interesting
it's an interesting question because
yeah there's a lot of things that
start to become kind of cheesy and
uninteresting over time
listening to two old guys uh like Mike
Austin
uh I will say something that is not
cheesy that I love this is complete left
field but just randomly thinking about
the all the game awards nominations I
was happy to see the new plague tale get
a handful of them because I freaking
love those games I'm way behind I've not
played the first one yet dude I don't
know what it is
put me off and I just was like no I
don't need that much
[ __ ] unnerving and they do they so
like they do such a good job at just
creating this right inner body leading
rats rendering right like really like
yeah they've they've they've pioneered
it in the way that uh Last of Us
pioneered the Rope yeah it's uh it's a
powerful stuff it really is I I it's one
of those where
again maybe maybe it's an interesting
maybe it was a subconscious connection
to the whole idea of what's cheesy but
like I find myself
so in love with the two voice actors who
who lead the brother and sister Hugo and
amicia
the boy has that classic like you
remember did you watch um
hunting at blind Manor the second Mike
Flanagan Netflix series I didn't you
gotta stop naming stuff I've not seen
but yet I've not seen that I'm not
that's that's the one did you see Thomas
Was Alone no can we all get to it
eventually I heard the guy who made this
kind of a dick no I no I've um I I only
came into like Flanagan like with um
midnight mass yeah I mean that's his
crowning achievement so far but but um
but in blind manner there's these little
kids and they've got the classic like
Mary Poppins young British like well
hello there like there's just so little
sound to Childhood that's the thing like
it it felt it felt cute but overwrought
uh a bit to me in blind Manor but it
wasn't it wasn't uh it didn't turn me
off of the show and there were times
where I found them actually really
Charming but it does have a bit of a
kind of almost like cartoon British
child and if if I if I zoom out I try to
be objective Hugo the the brother in a
plague Tale
talks despite the fact that it takes
place in like 11th century France he
basically has that exact voice where
he's like amicia what are we going to do
like it feels
sort of like
sort of dialed up to 10 adorable British
child to my ear certainly doesn't sound
like a French accent to me
um but that's that's the Tale As Old As
Time uh British being the standard
European voice yeah well yeah well and
In fairness I think I think they have
like I think it's because I bought it in
America and it defaulted to like I think
they if I had to guess that game because
it's a French developer I I bet they
have essentially two main actors I bet
they have like an English language main
one but an equally not just like
localization but one they probably put
just as much care into auditioning all
that if I had to guess I don't know that
but I would be surprised if not because
it's just such a well-made game and so
thought out in so many ways but in any
case the the boy
he's so like I'm gonna be adorable
painfully so all the time but it just
works for me it's one of those where I'm
like I don't know why this doesn't feel
cheesy I but I need to protect this
child it is working it is intended
function so effectively to me uh that
like I yeah I don't know what to make of
it uh I don't know why it doesn't read
as cheesy because they they go hard on
it in the sequel as well and I [ __ ]
loved every minute of the sequel so I
have no explanation
sometimes sometimes you've got to put a
a bit of grit in the uh to in the Oyster
right to get the Pearl like I think
sometimes you do have to have a little a
little thing that dings a bit can
actually make it cuter potentially will
make you care about that character more
because they're imperfect maybe that's
what it is but it doesn't read as an
imperfect character it reads as like
again I had to force myself to try to
objectively listen to it because I just
found myself loving I just found myself
really loving it and then I zoomed out
and I thought I bet this is actually
kind of cheesy and I don't know why I
don't feel like it is I I just to me it
reads I just kept marveling I kept going
this is such great performance in this
in these games for both of them although
I do think that
the second one does fall a little bit
prey to the sister your playable
character of amicia being like
you know kind of
hyper aggressively urgent in way like
occasionally in moments where it feels
like
that emotion has been played out like
three times consecutively and there's
you're not doing there's nothing new
happening here so probably a script
thing more than an actor thing but over
a second story in a Trilogy thing maybe
that could be you you kind of have to
keep your I don't know you know again I
will avoid spoilers but
um while I could imagine them making a
third
um it definitely ends in a way that if
it if it were to end here
uh it's a good it's a good ending it
works like it's a good way to like I I
imagine I I mean look the first one was
especially for the size team I think the
first one was quite successful and I
think the second one has you know come
exploding out of the gate as well uh I I
recommend it I played it because I was
doing a podcast with the composer uh
French composer Olivier deriviera and I
realized I haven't played any of this
guy's games so I went on a bench and
played like all of his kind of most
well-known games but this one was
probably the most famous
um well I guess the original thing that
kind of put him on the map was that game
remember me from like 10 years ago I
really have a soft spot for that game
I've got the art book of that game it
was the game itself wasn't incredible
but the art of it was really nice that
kind of minimalist kind of futuristic
kind of a bit mirrors edgy a bit it was
nice aesthetic yeah yep yep and his
score to that was very
interesting like very I don't know how
else to describe it than to say
uh Progressive because it was like he
did a thing I'd always fantasized about
doing something along these lines and
then he just kind of went for it in a
way it was different than what I would
have done but just so compelling where
you know he recorded a big orchestral
score but he always had the orchestra
kind of broken up into constituent Parts
in the way that he recorded So that like
you're listening to the orchestra and
then he starts to apply weird effects on
like the strings only so you'll have
brass playing a melody and then the
strings start to like glitch out and
it's like so it's like imagine you're at
a concert looking at a sea of musicians
and some subset of them randomly start
to get pixelated like despite the fact
that they're all playing together and I
remember going inside down for no reason
whatsoever
not working on anything that would be
relevant for that and I did have a look
behind me because I do own the art book
but I think it must be downstairs I
can't see that there which is annoying
so I'm so sorry that would have been the
best bookshelf grab I've ever done if I
hadn't had it there oh well oh well well
look we are at an interesting Crossroad
because I have to leave
shortly I think Troy is awesome
you might need a monologue
genius thing
uh all right sir well good luck
well listener
um it is now just you and me I'm just
gonna read we can cut this in maybe if
you want um I'm going to read from the
Tron Junior novelization
when Sam Flynn was a little boy his dad
Kevin told him a story every night
before he went back to the office
Kevin didn't work the night shift or
anything he owned a software company
ncom and he worked there a lot
Sam loved his father's stories because
they were almost always about Tron the
hero of the popular video game his dad
had invented the grid is the digital
Frontier Kevin would tell Sam add
Quantum pairing biodigital teleportation
enfoldment and they have the power to
change everything
hold up Dad Sam would think I'm only
seven
just page one we're off
even though Sam wasn't quite old enough
to understand everything Stan said he
loved the stories anyway and would
always try to follow along
I imagine what it looked like inside the
computer Kevin would say to his son I
kept dreaming of a world I thought I'd
never see
this is uh the opening of the movie that
one day you got in Sam finished always
right on cue I got in his dad with Echo
Sam understood this part of the story
his dad had actually gotten onto into a
computer he'd play the games from the
inside
the World Behind the computer screen was
very beautiful and more dangerous than I
ever imagined his father would explain
but with the help of a brave Warrior
named Tron I took down the evil master
control program then I got back out
the story always ended there except for
one important night
I tried to forget the digital world
Kevin informed his son but I couldn't
let it go
I kept tinkering and one day I got
inside again
Sam got excited this part of the story
was new
it was my world my creation Kevin said
but he helped to build a new system so I
created a program that could think like
me like you I named it codified likeness
utility or clue for short
but then something unexpected happened a
miracle his father did not go on
Sam pleaded with him to stay home that
night Sam wanted to hear more of the
story but Kevin shook his head
I have to go Sam his dad said I wish I
wish I had a Jeff bridger's impression
we've got to see how the story ends
right Sam nodded but his eyes were
filled with disappointment
trying to cheer him up Kevin promised
Sam that they would go to Flynn's arcade
first thing the next morning
they could play a couple of levels of
the games that Kevin had invented space
paranoids and of course Tron
can we play on the same team Sam asked
we're always on the same team kiddo his
father said before stepping out of the
bedroom
they were always in it together
that wasn't true
that night
Kevin Flynn
disappeared
and I believe I'm I'm veering into uh
copyright uh
lore at this point by reading any more
I'm still on my own
I'm gonna go mad slowly but surely many
years passed
and the pain from his father's
disappearance stayed with Sam refusing
to fade his dad's last words still
echoed inside Sam's brain we're always
on the same team kilo
Sam shook his head angrily trying to
drown out the words he revved his
motorcycle's engine the wall of noise
battered his ears but the memories would
not go away
some team we are Sam thought I'm here
Dad I've been here all along where the
heck are you
heat lightning rippled across the night
sky
up ahead cars hurtled along the freeway
without warning traffic slow to a cruel
bright red brake lights blinked in the
night
instead of slowing down Sam sped up
expertly darting his bike around the
Scarlet light I do like as an aside I
love that the openings Legacy
establishes every single skill he could
need for the rest of the movie it's good
I had to get there on time he thought
especially tonight
it was exactly 20 years ago to the day
that Sam's dad had finished his bedtime
story left for the office and vanished
at the time Kevin Flynn's disappearance
had been front page news after all he
owned one of the biggest companies in
the world that was a huge media circus
reporters camped out in front of Sam's
home but the stories were all about the
fate of encom no one really cared about
him I feel like I'm filibustering no one
really cared about young Sam he was just
a kid with a mum who died a few years
before and a genius dad who'd gone
missing without even saying goodbye
it's that stupid companies fault my dad
is gone Sam thought aincon was always
more important to Dad than me
after his father vanished Sam inherited
a huge stake in his company but Sam
didn't care he pretended the company
didn't accept exist except on one day
every year the anniversary of his
father's disappearance
every year on that day Sam pranked encom
once he performed a flaming motorcycle
stunt to the company barbecue another
year he hacked into the CEO's computer
then there was the time HE bungee jumped
during a big press junker Sam knew these
wild pranks could never make up for a
life without his father but the stunts
gave him satisfaction this is good
backstory on that one day a year he made
sure everyone at encom remembered that
he was still here and that his dad
wasn't
it was in a weird way his only
connection to the father who probably
never see again
tonight's very special anniversary Sam
had planned something really spectacular
pulling free of his memories Sam gave a
sharp jerk on his motorcycle handlebars
and cut across six Lanes of traffic he
blew down an off-ramp ran a red light
and swerved into a narrow alley finally
he parked I have this by the way on my
desk because
um it's useful for spellings and uh for
terminology
I've lost my space without a little side
ran a red light and swerved into a
narrow alley finally he parked the cycle
on a big Commercial Boulevard in the
daylight hours these streets were very
busy now they were dark and deserted
everyone was home with their families
with his backpack slung over his
shoulder Sam jogged towards encom Tower
in the quiet Shadows of the Night a
young man joined him the kid wore a dark
hoodie black jeans and dark sneakers
this was Sobel he was an acquaintance of
Sam's Sam didn't have friends
you were on time sober whispered
gleefully that's good synchronization is
good together the two jogged to a steel
security door uh near encom's loading
dock sampled up the cord hanging around
his neck attached to it was a USB device
he plugged the device into the
electronic door lock and he connected to
a handheld keypad with a tiny LED screen
we taped out on the big guy up there
sober whispered that is Assassin cool
that is rep bro
I assume this wasn't going to be a
British actor
um huge rep Sam quietly replied still
working the keypad but why are we always
messing with the same guys Sobel asked I
know their Master of the Universe
corporate evil style but I want to hit
other villains too my game is too strong
for just one enemy
um
you do have mad games
do have bad game uh his eyes from
hundreds of Cipher codes running through
his device he knew one of them would
open the lock you're courageous Sam
Sobel said you're my Butch Cassidy this
is just the beginning
so I've noticed something on the screen
just then uh oh what's up so the last
worrying his voice they added a new
security Cipher Sam explained the code I
hit I might have just called the cops
Sobel eyes grew big cops Sam Shrugged so
we get caught
this is where reps are made assassin
but now Sobel had gone completely pale
if I'm caught by the cops call my
stepmom
if I'm caught by the cops I assume I
mean they'll call my stepmom he took off
down the street my stepmom Sam rolled
his eyes figured the only person he can
rely on was himself okay Sundance he
called see you on the flip side he added
silently
just then the multiple locks clicked uh
and the security door opened Sam smiled
tucked the USB device into his jacket
and slung his backpack over his shoulder
then he took a deep breath and darted
through the door
I'm gonna have to stop
I do I do like it in normalizations
where you get scenes that are different
than what was in the movie it's
interesting right I start recording
cheers I don't know if this is usable
bye